on connaissait les guides gastronomiques
les guides des vins et bien voici
maintenant le guide du pain et plus
précisément de la baguette artisanale
sous l'appellation d'origine contrôlée
premier paradoxe est un américain qui en
est l'auteur deuxième paradoxe est en
ville qu'on mange la meilleure baguette
sans boulangerie parisienne ont été
notés françois jullien pieds-noirs
grégory vasseur le cliché du français ou
presque la baguette sous le bras mais la
casquette de baseball a détrôné le béret
à paris un américain spécialiste du pain
il y a trente ans il goûte sa première
baguette c'est la révélation
c'était un coup de feu je me suis dit
voilà je cherchais une façon de pénétrer
au fond de ce que c'était la france j'ai
compris que c'était le 6 en boulangerie
visiter et des milliers de baguettes
déguster pour sélectionner les meilleurs
de paris n'ont pas n'est pas blanc il
est rom passage dans sa boulangerie
préféré la mieux classée dans son guide
ici il est considéré comme le
connaisseur ce soit un français que ce
soit un américain ce qui est important
c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui se disent
pas je suis capable de juger ne soit pas
capable mais s'il est tout à fait
capable est tout à fait apte et
passionné par la france
mais en américain critique des
boulangers parisiens ça peut agacer
crois que lui peut les apporter quelque
chose
j'ai rien quand vous avez un quelconque
rejoint l'américain j'écris toujours
bien accompagné le pain français le
meilleur au monde selon lui il faut dire
qu'il n'est pas gâté de là d'où il vient
soyons clairs je suis pas subversif je
ne veux pas comme monsieur bush me
foutant dole mais le pari américain
il est dégueulasse bref on en est
désormais certain 98 % des français
mangent du pain et au moins un américain